my name is Jim DeCarlo I'm an associate
professor of neuroscience at the
McGovern Institute for brain research at
MIT the brain is essentially a computing
device I like to think of this network
of tissue is it's like a device from the
future has been given to us and we have
the privilege of figuring out how it
actually works and it's just sitting
there between our ears waiting to be
discovered the problem that our lab is
most interested in is the problem of
visual object recognition and that's the
ability of you to recognize my face or
any other object that you've encountered
very very quickly this is something that
we do remarkably well yet machines are
still very far behind us even after
decades of work of trying to emulate our
abilities in terms of solving visual
recognition we have this intuition that
our brain is somehow storing photographs
in its head but it's it's storing
nothing like photographs it's during
transformed patterns of neural activity
so it takes the photograph on your eye
and transforms it to some new pattern of
neural activity a new neuronal code that
represents the object and how that
computation occurs we still don't know
and so our lab is structured its work in
two directions one direction is to
understand the nature of that code in
these high-level regions of your brain
if we understand the spatial nature and
temporal nature of those neural patterns
of activity we might someday be able to
interact with that code so as to replace
lost function or to augment normal and
if we understand that code that leads to
our second line of work which is that we
might be able to understand how to even
compute that code how to build machines
that compute like our brain computes
the central computational problem of
visual recognition is your ability to
recognize an object in a way that's
tolerant or invariant to transformations
of its image so when you look at my face
you can still recognize it to my face
even if I change my post slightly or the
illumination conditions on me there are
two basic hypotheses of how the brain
can solve that problem one is that the
brain automatically computes this
somehow when it learned is an
information at one position
it's innately able to move that
information to other positions and
therefore recognize across the position
the other theory is that the brain is
constantly learning from the visual
environment that it lives in it's using
the visual inputs to learn what objects
look like at different positions our
recent work showed that that second
theory is much more likely to be true we
showed that if we manipulate the
experience of a subject while they're
making eye movements to different
objects that is while they're varying
the position of the object on the retina
we can alter their perception and their
neurons in a way that's consistent with
them using that information to learn
what an object looks like at different
positions our work is fundamentally
basic science we want to understand how
this computer between our ears is able
to do this remarkable process of visual
recognition the likely applications of
understanding Network are first going to
be computer vision applications so as we
understand how our brain does this we
take those ideas and build computer
vision systems that work more like our
own brain the longer-term view is that
as we understand these basic processes
then we can think about molecular tools
to improve function or to restore
function for individuals that have lost
the function of that part of their brain
neuroscience is really ripe for progress
right now especially at the interface of
neuroscience itself and computer science
on the neuroscience side we have
developments and technology where we can
better monitor the electoral activity of
neurons and these networks that are
doing the computing and on a
computational side we have this
inexorable advance of computing power
and it's the synergy of those two that I
think is most exciting
you